things you know before you go things to  know before you go  [Music]  [Applause]  we are in search of warriors warriors  who serve the good and the light of the  universe meg is not the best girl or  teenager and she's not perfect and she's  perfect at being imperfect so to speak  your father's trapped by an evil of  energy it's too strong for our light it  and Camazotz and the darkness are all  the same thing Camazotz is a planet of  many faces  it will change on you in a second don't  get comfortable I trust you make sure  and bring a kid with you you'll have  that much more fun buy some tissues  because at the end is there some  profoundest drops that made me cry my  love is always there even if she can't  see it go to see this movie because you  want to be delighted you want to feel  like a kid again you want to be caught  up in this beautiful magical experience  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]